wir hatten zur Beginn der Sendung schon
drüber gesprochen dass Kinder in den
letzten Jahren einiges an Chancen
eingebüßt haben gerade wenn es um
Bildung und gesellschaftliche Teilhabe
geht und dann müssen wir dringend was
tun wenn wir über Kinderarmut sprechen
sprechen wir viel zu oft nur über den
materiellen Teil von Armut aber ein viel
größerer oder auch ein sehr großer Teil
ein sehr wichtiger Teil davon hat eben
mit der Abwesenheit von Chancen zu
Teilhabe an unserer Gesellschaft von
Chancen auf Bildung und damit
Aufstiegschancen zu tun und auch mit
Räumen indem dein
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung stattfinden
kann mir ist wichtig dass wir mehr
darüber sprechen was kann man tun Kinder
dabei zu unterstützen wir haben eben
Koalitionsvertrag ein
kinderschossenportal vereinbart des
Leistungen die es schon gibt die
brauchen kein neues Gesetz dafür es gibt
es Bildungs- und teilhabepaket mit dem
Verwaltung und Vereine schon lange
Erfahrung haben aber es ist viel zu
kompliziert und kommt nicht bei den
Kindern an diesem dringendsten brauchen
den Zugang müssen wir einfachen damit
Kinder einfach die Chancen haben die Sie
brauchen um gut ins Leben zu starten
also machen wir es einmal konkret was
können wir für diese Kinder tun den der
Zugang zu allem möglichen so erschwert
wird ein erster Schritt ich mache es mal
plastisch ich war vor meiner Zeit im
Bundestag im Jobcenter und habe
tatsächlich diese Leistungen ausgereicht
des
bildungseinteilhabepakets da werden zum
Beispiel Schulausflüge darüber bezahlt
und das läuft bisher so die Eltern
müssen beim Jobcentern Formular abholen
dass dem Kind mitgeben der Lehrer muss
das Ausfüllen das Kind muss das
ausgefüllte Formular wieder unfallfrei
nach Hause bringen die Eltern bringen
das dann wieder ins Amt und dann
irgendwann werden 20 € für den
Schulausflug überwiesen wer schon mal
mit achtjährigen Kindern umgegangen ist
weiß wie viele Fallstricke auf diesen
Weg da liegen und wie viele Flecken dann
da auf diesen Formular sind und das kann
einfach nicht funktionieren unsere
Vorstellung ist dass es so einfach ist
wie bei einem Amazon Warenkorb dann wäre
Zugang hat zu diesen Leistungen die
online abzurufen vielleicht sogar wenn
die Schule im Spiel ist läuft das von
Behörde zu Behörde direkt und dann
online in der Pandemie haben wir gesehen
den Schulen und online das ist jetzt
nicht unbedingt immer natürlich der
große Unterschied der
fortschrittskoalition zuletzten dass wir
von diesem was verstehen und das dann
auch aufs Gleise bekommen und das ist
jetzt glaube ich dringend dass wir dass
wir das tun und für arme Kinder da was
gutes einfach zustande bekommen
und ohne Gas das glaube ich nicht
treten nein im Januar auch hier einfach
wieder ja hoffentlich haben wir da ein
Licht an
nein aber wirklich ich werde da noch
einmal ernst drüber sprechen über die
Kinder was wird Ihnen geschildert wie
nah sind sie wirklich dran was sehen Sie
bei Kindern in Armut in Deutschland also
ich habe gesehen dass es ein Unterschied
macht wenn Kinder die gleichen
materiellen Mittel zur Verfügung haben
weil sie zum Beispiel SGB II-Leistungen
bekommen also volkstümliche Hartz IV
bald Bürgergeld wenn Eltern wissen wie
man Teilhabe an Gesellschaft gestaltet
dann weiß also wenn ich will dass mein
Kind Fußball spielt und ich weiß ich
muss dazu zum Vereinsvorstand gehen und
sagen mein Mädchen möchte gerne bei Euch
mitkicken ich kann mir aber den
beitragen nicht leisten und weiß die
meisten Vereine finden dann schon eine
Lösung dass das klappt
haben
eröffnet seinen Kindern dann große
Chancen zu Teilhabe wer sich vielleicht
bei uns nicht so gut in der Gesellschaft
auskennt oder von der Bürokratie
überfordert ist der kann seinen Kindern
dann diesen Weg nicht eröffnen der ihn
viel helfen würde ich denk zum Beispiel
eine Mutter die aus der Ukraine
geflüchtet ist mit zwei Kindern die sehr
viele Sorgen hat eine Sprachbarriere hat
aber weiß wenn man Kind am Mittwoch
Abend eine Runde Fußball spielen könnte
das wird ihm sehr Ablenkung dann müssen
wir das einfach in dieser schwierig
zugänglich machen
Zettel haben schauen wir genauer weiter
drauf wie das auch gelingt dass man
allen Kindern die gleichen Chancen geben
kann großer Wunsch hier auch vielen
herzlichen Dank